Recently, Congressional Republicans proposed
changing the tax treatment for the 401(k)
accounts that most Americans use to save for
retirement.
Instead of receiving a tax deduction on 401(k)
contributions, the tax plan would have taxed
these contributions but allowed withdrawals
to be tax-free.
Opposition to this was strong enough that
President Trump himself came out against
it on Twitter, and when Congressional Republicans
released their tax plan in early November, the idea
had fallen through entirely.
But what was this all about?
Some people were concerned that without the
up-front tax break on their contributions,
Americans would not contribute enough to their 401(k)s.
That’s possible.
But other research finds that most employees
will keep saving at the same rates even if
the tax preference changes.
This could increase retirement incomes, by
having taxes paid up front and making
withdrawals tax-free.
Whatever the truth is, the Republican sponsors
of the tax bill made no mention of these issues;
instead, they focused on using the higher
upfront tax revenues from Roth 401(k)s to
pay for a tax cut.
What do you think about how the Republican tax plan would affect retirement savings?
Let us know in your comments. Also, let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 Seconds, and be sure to like and subscribe for more research
and videos from AEI.